bonsoir et bienvenue dans ça vous
regarder ravi de vous retrouver notre
grand témoin ce soir crois dans les
pouvoirs de la littérature et si les
grands chefs les grands récits
littéraires nous aidaient à faire face
aux crises qui nous assaillent de toutes
parts Frédéric lichterflack bonsoir
bonsoir pourquoi le mal frappe les gens
bien quel titre c'est celui que vous
avez choisi pour votre dernier essai
passionnant chez Flammarion et en ces
temps de guerre de pandémie et de crise
climatiques la question nous installe
elle est essentielle on va en parler
longuement tout à l'heure on est
ensemble pendant une heure pour
décrypter l'actualité de ce vendredi 27
janvier au sommaire ce soir backlash mot
anglais mot qui signifie retour de bâton
alors assiste-t-on à un contrecoup
réactionnaire 5 ans après MiTo c'est ce
que semble indiquer le rapport du Haut
Conseil à l'égalité publiée cette
semaine nous poussait misogyne
inquiétante voir masculiniste qui
frapperait surtout les plus jeunes
Français dans notre d'autres pays alors
comment comprendre tout cela et surtout
comment y répondre ce sera notre grand
débat dans un instant avec nos invités
avant de retrouver à 20h15 nous
affranchis pour leur partie prix et puis
gourmand Express bien sûr avec Marco
pommier ce soir l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée nous parle des députés
handicapés voilà Frédéric vous me suivez
ça vous regarde c'est parti
[Musique]
c'est donc d'un rapport inquiétant dont
on va parler ce soir il montre que le
sexisme ne recule pas pire certaines de
ces manifestations s'aggravent et
touchent particulièrement les plus
jeunes bonsoir Sylvie Pierre Brossolette
bonsoir et merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté notre invitation vous êtes la
présidente du Haut Conseil à l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes vous avez
remis votre rapport mercredi au
président de la République vous nous
direz peut-être d'ailleurs comment s'est
déroulée cette réunion avec le chef de
l'État bonsoir maître Tomasini et merci
d'être avec nous d'être avocate
spécialiste sur contre la lutte des
violences faites aux femmes bonsoir les
à chamboncelles vidage familier dans
cette émission vous êtes chroniqueuse
vous êtes journaliste vous êtes
militante féministe et vous êtes la
fondatrice de popol média enfin un homme
sur ce plateau oui parce que ce combat
il passe aussi par les hommes bonsoir
Maxime Brunet ski et merci d'être là
vous êtes le co-fondateur avec
Anne-Cécile mayfer de la Fondation des
femmes et de remix
en deux mots c'est une entreprise qui
forme aussi sensibiliser salariés au
sujet de diversité inclusion dont le
sexisme et aujourd'hui ce qu'on
malheureusement on enseigne le plus
Frédéric lichterfly que vous
enseignation SPO les humanités
politiques Sciences Po je suis sûr que
voilà le sujet on en parle et à la
pointe sur ce sujet de formation des
enseignants et des étudiants et
l'ensemble des communautés de
l'enseignement supérieur contre les
violences n'hésitez pas à intervenir
parce que je crois voilà que les
étudiants parfois en parlent et ça
s'invite dans y compris dans les dans
les grands amphithéâtres alors je vous
donne la parole dans un tout petit
instant on a besoin de planter le décor
que dit ce rapport c'est Stéphane
blackowski qu'on accueille tout de suite
qui va nous le dire en moins de 200
secondes quel défi le chrono de Blacko
tout de suite
et on se tourne pour vous accueillir
cher Stéphane
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir Monsieur aussi
bonjour bonsoir alors ce rapport alors
ce rapport ce soir on parle donc d'un
rapport de 40 pages qui a été publié
cette semaine par le HCE vous le
rappeler au comité à l'égalité des
hommes plus connus des femmes je dis
conseil vous avez des comité
pour les femmes et les hommes dans la
présidente est avec nous ce soir donc je
suis peut-être trompé pour ça il y a
tellement de hauts comité en France
évidemment de rapport sur tellement de
sujets que si on veut se faire remarquer
il faut faire un résumé percutant et là
c'est réussi parce que le HCE son résumé
il est effectivement très inquiétant
dans la mesure où non seulement on
constate avec cette enquête que le
sexisme progresse en France mais surtout
que là où il progresse le plus c'est
chez les plus jeunes et donc c'est
évidemment inquiétant pour l'avenir
c'est inquiétant c'est même un peu enfin
déprimant en tout cas pour des gens de
ma génération parce que on avait le
sentiment que les progrès des droits des
femmes c'était quelque chose d'un peu
constant il y a des images comme
celle-ci qu'on peut trouver sur les
sites fémin conquête après conquête on a
fait progresser les devoirs des femmes
et on avait des sentiments que ça
progresserait comme ça jusqu'à l'égalité
un jour sauf que ce que dit le chez eux
c'est ce fameux backlash dont vous
parlez donc il est trop tour de bâton je
dis retour de manivelle c'est-à-dire
qu'on a effectivement beaucoup combattu
le sexisme mais c'est comme si il se
défendait aujourd'hui et qui avait une
forme de résurgence alors moi il est
chiffres qui sont vraiment très très
frappant dans l'espace public par
exemple où on en est 80% des femmes ont
déjà eu peur de sortir seul le soir
quand elles sont chez elles 55 % ont
renoncé la sortir pareil par peur d'être
importuné puis à la fin regardez la
moitié des femmes plus de la moitié ont
déjà renoncé à s'habiller pour éviter
des commentaires et c'est encore plus
important
68% chez les 15 24 ça veut dire que donc
c'est ce phénomène-là est très très
présent dans les établissements
scolaires donc là il y a vraiment du
gros boulot pour Gérard Darmanin on va
dire mais c'est pareil aussi dans
l'espace intime je vous cite je vous
montre deux chiffres qui sont dans le
rapport vous voyez un tiers des femmes
disent qu'elles ont des rues en rapport
non consentis avec leur partenaires
c'est-à-dire à force d'insistance mais
apparemment les hommes ne l'ont pas
l'air de se rendre compte parce que pour
eux oui peut-être 12% disent que ça a pu
arriver puis surtout il y a ce chiffre
qu'on a beaucoup repris dans les médias
qui est et tout en bas le chiffre vous
voyez 23 % des hommes de moins de 35 ans
disent que se montrer violence c'est une
manière de correspondre à l'image que
l'homme que la société attend des hommes
pour être respecté pour être en
respecter donc attention faut pas
comprendre que c'est 23% des hommes qui
sont prêts à taper leurs femmes pour se
faire respecter c'est pas du tout ça la
question c'est les comportements en
général donc cette violence ça peut être
je sais pas se battre c'est une voiture
à la sortie d'une boîte c'est
complètement con mais ce n'est pas de la
violence dirigée contre les femmes
précisément surtout qu'on pourrait
regarder aussi le haut du classement
puisqu'on regarde le bas et donc on voit
dans l'eau du classement les vrais
pressions qui s'existent ce sera les
hommes pour avoir l'air viril aux yeux
de la société c'est pas ça c'est prendre
soin financièrement de sa famille et
réussir sa vie professionnelle donc
j'admets il y a sans doute un peu de
sexisme mais là dedans peut-être il
faudrait déconstruire c'est quand même
pas non plus aussi alarmant que les
questions de violence mais là quand je
dis ça je sens que je suis en train de
prêter le flan à un des reproches qui
est pointé dans le rapport c'est à dire
qu'en fait les hommes ont beaucoup de
mal à accepter l'ampleur du sexisme en
société regardez le chiffre 70 % d'entre
nous je vais dire pense que ça serait
généralisé de dire que les hommes sont
tous sexistes et de fait ça parce que je
pense donc je vois je comprends pas
parce que si tous les hommes sont
sexistes comment on va faire pour les
faire changer parce que il suffit d'être
un homme pour être sexiste alors du coup
on est condamnés
je vais commencer par vous c'est vrai
que ce que remonte le rapport c'est le
décalage de perception sur la question
du sexisme entre les femmes et les
hommes ça ça c'est très très frappant on
va parler de la question des violences
sexuelles avec Maître thomasini mais sur
le sexisme le sexisme ordinaire là on
est très très loin du compte les hommes
ne se rendent pas compte de ce que les
femmes vivent vraiment aujourd'hui
non ce que ce rapport montre c'est pas
forcément une aggravation ou un backlash
c'est la persistance du sexisme on a cru
qu'avec les nouveaux droits qui ont été
accordés effectivement vous l'avez très
bien montré depuis des années les femmes
ont quasiment conquis des droits à
égalité avec les hommes mais le décalage
entre les droits et le vécu des femmes
et la pratique des hommes est encore
très importante et malheureusement on a
constaté qu'il était plutôt encore plus
important dans la génération des 25 34
ans dont on pouvait espérer
qu'effectivement depuis une dizaine
d'années et puis en particulier
l'adhésion unanime dont les jeunes aux
valeurs d'égalité à la nécessité de
lutter contre les violences et le
sexisme on dit que c'est très très bien
et puis après dans la réalité il se
passe des choses différentes
c'est-à-dire que la jeune génération
dirait bah maintenant ça suffit au fond
le mytho c'est une forme progression
aussi vis-à-vis de notre propre sexe
vous n'y croyez pas si si il y a
sûrement ça et d'ailleurs il y a des
mouvements qui se manifestent partout
dans le monde
particulièrement aux États-Unis parce
que c'est toujours le début de tous les
États-Unis et en France aussi il y a un
espèce de ras-le-bol des hommes parce
que justement on ne parle que des femmes
on parlait des violences faites aux
femmes des nominations de femmes donc
c'est humain leur domination a été
millénaire et tout d'un coup on leur dit
attention faut laisser un peu la place
il faut demander son consentement à
votre conjoint tout le monde
les femmes ont le droit de faire tous
les métiers
ils ont une réaction et une part de
réaction
mais pas forcément une plongée dans la
guerre des sexes pourquoi on a voulu
examiner ça d'abord c'est notre travail
de
pour remettre au gouvernement une
analyse de l'état du sexisme mais c'est
la deuxième année qu'on a les moyens de
faire un baromètre comme la CNCDH le
fait sur l'état du racisme et donc il
fallait vraiment mesurer son délire si
je peux dire et c'est là qu'on se
rencontre que
les femmes ont un vécu terrible vous
l'avez très bien montré peut-être
qu'elles ont plus tendance aujourd'hui à
le dire et à se rendre compte qui est
une bonne nouvelle c'est qu'elle résiste
à cet état de choses mais c'est encore
comme ça et que c'est très très
difficile d'extirper le sexisme des
cerveaux des mentalités
et que malheureusement ce que vous lui
démontrer c'est que le sexisme est un
continuum c'est que quand ça commence
par le sexisme d'iordinaire les choses
du quotidien ça finit mal c'est
d'ailleurs le thème de notre campagne le
sexisme on ne sait pas toujours quand ça
commence mais on sait comment ça se
termine avec le nombre de féminicides
qu'on connaît d'où notre
conclusion qui est il faut lutter non
seulement contre les violences
évidemment faut le faire mais à la base
à racines prendre le mal à la racine et
lutter contre le sexisme alors maître
thomasini vous la question du côté
continuum de la violence sexiste à la
violence sexuelle vous la voyez tous les
jours au quotidien dans les salles
d'audience et quelques chiffres sur la
dimension la plus alarmante de ce
rapport quand même 122 femmes tuées par
leur conjoint où est-ce qu'on joue en
2021 c'est 20 % de plus qu'en 2020 20%
de la population ne voit toujours pas de
quoi il s'agit quand on prononce le mot
de féminicide et 33% des femmes ont déjà
eu un rapport sexuel ça c'est le chiffre
qui est beaucoup revenu suite à
l'insistance de leur partenaire alors
qu'elle n'en avait pas envie vous
comment vous les accueillez ces chiffres
là alors plusieurs choses d'une part je
ne suis pas étonnée par le constat de ce
rapport à savoir que dans mon cabinet je
reçois de plus en plus de femmes très
jeunes qui sont victimes de violences
conjugales de par des compagnons très
jeunes également quand je dis très jeune
c'est la vingtaine
donc je ne suis pas du tout étonnée
maintenant je suis catastrophe
par ce rapport non pas par son constat
qui pour moi ne m'étonne pas mais par le
fait que on est encore au stade des
préconisations
on est en France au gouvernement n'a pas
rien fait
dans yakaland voilà il y a qu'à il y a
qu'à il y a qu'à Yaka
aujourd'hui le contenu est pas en termes
de budget et on termine de mesures
cruciales c'est-à-dire que on a un
modèle encore une fois le modèle
espagnol est d'ailleurs c'est repris
dont le rapport
de ne faire déjà qu'un copier-coller
c'est pas extraordinaire vous
reconnaissez quand même que les les
policiers ont été formés
au niveau aujourd'hui et d'ailleurs dans
le rapport on parle de la formation des
magistrats qui n'est pas encore
effective on parle également
d'enseignement c'est à dire que
apprendre
l'égalité des droits entre une petite
fille un petit garçon entre un homme et
une femme ça s'apprend dès l'école et je
répondrai à votre intervenant qui a
expliqué que comment faire pour changer
les hommes c'est très simple ça passe
par l'éducation et ce sont les femmes
les mères qui ont ce devoir mais pas que
la société dans son ensemble parce qu'en
fait on va en parler des solutions donc
c'est un espèce de de liquide amniotique
sociétal où on est imprégné par
l'éducation sociale c'est-à-dire les
médias la culture
et l'éducation effectivement dans les
lycées et autres dont les alors vous
arrivez tout de suite sur les solutions
j'aurais voulu qu'on reste un poil sur
le diagnostic un peu plus longtemps mais
on va on va tout de suite y aller mais
je voudrais
préciser que le sexisme effectivement
est le préalable
trop violence intra familiale alors je
vous donne la parole dans un instant
pour terminer le tour de table sur le
diagnostic et venir aux solutions dans
un instant mais je voulais vous montrer
ce petit sujet qui a été préparé par
elsament d'un GABA et Pierre Michael
Carniel se rapporte s'est invité dans
dans les familles au travail ou même
dans les cours de collège Vous allez le
voir Sylvie bien bossolette paroles de
jeunes et de moins jeunes autour de
cette poussette de sexisme regardez
un sexisme vécu au quotidien ce qui est
fréquent et aussi ce qu'on apprend je
pense en tant que femme à oublier ou à
passer outre c'est un peu Léon gros tu
es bonne je vais te bouffer la chatte
dans la rue qui qui peuvent arriver à se
fréquemment quand on rentre notamment le
soir mais ça je dirais que et un peu
malheureusement aussi on finit par s'y
habituer des femmes obligées d'adapter
leurs habitudes
le soir surtout
j'essaye de faire attention un peu à
comment je fais habiller ça c'est le
plus triste c'est de faire attention à
comment je m'habille mon hiver ça va
mais on était c'est un peu chiant
j'essaye d'être accompagné de pas
rentrer trop tard éventuellement
et de marcher un peu vite mais le
sentiment que la nouvelle génération se
laisse moins faire c'est d'abord
l'attitude des femmes qui est beaucoup
plus
défensive et beaucoup plus autonome et
c'est très important leur autonomie
elles sont beaucoup plus libres donc non
plus du tout la même attitude par
rapport aux hommes les hommes justement
certains conscients qu'après Mitou il
faut réinventer les rapports amoureux je
pense qu'on peut toujours séduire mais
un peu différemment
tout simplement se reposer des questions
mais je pense que la séduction n'est pas
n'est pas n'est pas devenu impossible
simplement et elle est plus il faut la
maîtriser et pour beaucoup la conviction
que l'égalité viendra de l'éducation je
sais pas quand on éduque correctement
nos garçons
j'en ai deux donc je sais
qu'on leur définisse un petit peu le
consentement qu'est-ce que c'est
pourquoi
je changerai pas et non pas vraiment je
suis pas sexy je suis pas mal de choses
éduquer dès le plus jeune âge c'est une
des recommandations du Haut Conseil pour
l'égalité voilà on va venir aux
solutions mais je voulais vous entendre
quand même pour réagir à ces paroles de
jeunes de moins jeunes d'hommes et de
femmes qu'on a recueilli ce matin à
Paris les haches chamboncelle il y a des
renoncements quand même c'est fou
d'entendre ça les femmes renoncent à
toute une série de choses du quotidien
je pense vous comme moi Myriam ce sont
des situations que nous avons connues ce
sont des situations qui ont continué de
connaître enfin moi c'est depuis que
j'ai 14 ans que l'on me regarde dans la
rue et que l'on me siffle j'en ai
aujourd'hui 37 donc ça commence à bien
faire et il est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on a
un sentiment de ras-le-bol enfin moi il
m'arrive aujourd'hui d'avoir des
intercréations violentes avec des hommes
qui ont des comportements sexistes et
vraiment qui font du harcèlement pour
revenir à ce que vous disiez mettre et
je je voulais abonder dans votre sens il
est vrai que le bilan du gouvernement
est catastrophique parce que c'est quand
même la grande cause du quinquennat
c'est d'ailleurs la deuxième fois que
c'est la grande cause du quinquennat
donc si c'est la deuxième fois la grande
cause ça veut dire que pendant le
premier quinquennat ça a quand même
échoué sinon le problème aurait été
réglé et ce n'est pas le cas vous pensez
qu'on peut changer une société
uniquement par les pouvoirs publics la
loi c'est pas parce que naturellement
regardez ce qui s'est passé par exemple
sur le droit à l'avortement sur la peine
de mort enfin c'est des enjeux de
société qui sont très importants le
mariage pour tout et tous enfin c'est
des choses qui sont excessives
la loi de la moitié le gros problème à
mon sens c'est qu'aujourd'hui le
gouvernement manque d'une part d'une
vision stratégique
transversale globale qui soit structurel
au même titre que ce qu'elle a fait
l'Espagne avec des lois et de la du
travail interministériel sur la vraiment
la question notamment de la lutte contre
les violences et il y a un autre point
qui est aussi fondamental c'est qu'on a
une approche aujourd'hui très
sécuritaire de du traitement des
violences sexuelles et sexistes le
rapport le soul je vous dis à très juste
titre vous en parliez également on en
parle aussi d'ailleurs les personnes qui
sont interviewées sur le micro-trottoir
le disent aussi le l'éducation et le
parent pauvre de la politique publique
en France sur justement la lutte contre
le sexisme etc donc aujourd'hui il nous
manque une vision stratégique globale il
nous manque aussi de faire beaucoup
beaucoup d'efforts sur l'éducation il
faut de la formation il faut que ce soit
de la formation de masse il faut que la
formation soit aussi assurée d'une part
par les associations spécialisées mais
qui n'ont pas les moyens en réalité le
c'est la plus grande cause du
quinquennat les associations féministes
disent grande cause réclament les
associations plus petit budget de l'État
alors Maxime Maxime rusinati sur le
constat déjà et puis je vous promets
qu'on va aller éducation et on va parler
des réseaux sociaux et également c'est
vrai que pour changer la société il faut
changer aussi peut-être les hommes
est-ce qu'ils sont suffisamment
concernés dire awake vous voyez ce que
je veux dire voilà conscientiser parce
que quand on regarde le rapport là
encore on a l'impression que ils ont du
mal pas sentir concernés 54% des hommes
considèrent que les hommes et les femmes
sont traités pareil quatre hommes sur 10
pensent qu'on s'acharne sur les hommes
ce qui montre bien que finalement il y a
un décalage entre la médiatisation du
sujet de l'égalité entre les femmes et
des hommes qui forte heureusement va
crescendo notamment depuis la
déflagration de tout et parce qu'on a
des rapports très importants comme celui
du HCE qui nous permettent aujourd'hui
de parler de ce sujet donc il y a ce
décalage entre une médiatisation très
importante et un changement dans les
faits ce que disait mes camarades qui
n'est pas encore opérationnel et donc
oui pour répondre à votre question
Myriam je pense que les hommes n'ont pas
suffisamment pris conscience de
l'ampleur des inégalités qu'elle soit au
travail à la maison dans la rue c'est à
dire qu'il y a toujours ce cette idée
que ça arrive aux autres alors que
aujourd'hui on sait que par exemple dans
une salle de classe ou dans une
entreprise il y a forcément une personne
autour de soi qui est victime de sexisme
voire même de violences sexistes et
sexuelles et sur l'éducation qui est
vraiment le facteur clé ce qu'il faut
aussi avoir en tête c'est que oui le
gouvernement peut faire plus mais la
société doit aussi bouger moi je me
rappelle qu'un peu plus de 10 ans quand
j'étais conseiller au ministère des
Droits des Femmes il y avait eu une
opposition de militants parce qu'il faut
voilà il faut dire ce qui s'est passé à
l'époque avec
Belkacem qui ont bloqué l'apprentissage
des ABCD de d'égalité qui était
justement un petit module tout à fait
inoffensif pour apprendre des qualités
entre les garçons et les filles ce qui
montre bien que la responsabilité n'est
pas seulement gouvernementale et pour
conclure sur ce point je vraiment je
m'adresse à celles et ceux qui croient
en l'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes il faut le dire il faut le dire à
l'école il faut le dire dans
l'entreprise il faut le dire partout
parce que ce qui se passe en France
comme dans d'autres pays surtout latin
c'est que ce sont des opposantes et les
opposants parce qu'il y a aussi des
opposantes qui se manifestent davantage
on en a marre des quotas on parle trop
d'égalité les hommes sont tous des
criminels en puissance alors que
personne ne dit ça en revanche celles et
ceux qui veulent que ça change souvent
n'osent pas trop ou parfois ils ont
Sylvie elle prend la parole mais moi je
le fais aussi et on tous les quatre mais
il faut que monsieur madame tout le
monde se pose des questions que ce soit
à l'école à la maison au travail dans la
rue partout alors dans le sexisme c'est
intéressant dans le rapport aussi il y a
évidemment une très très grosse
connotation négative mais c'est pas
forcément des moqueries c'est pas
forcément des regards des gestes
déplacés ça peut être des stéréotypes du
quotidien
est-ce que c'est normal qu'une femme
fasse la cuisine tous les jours pour
toute la famille oui pour 63% des hommes
c'est du sexisme ça pour vous c'est
indéniable ce sont des comme je le
disais des millénaires d'habitude
quand les hommes ont vécu avec un modèle
où ils ont vu leur mère faire ça leur
famille faire ça ou c'est les femmes qui
même entre nous ou on se dit un peu plus
évolué j'espère que la moyenne de ce que
reflète ce rapport ça nous arrive
souvent plus souvent les femmes de se
lever de table pendant la dîner de
copains pour aller ranger les plats que
les hommes l'addition aussi fait
beaucoup réagir il y a fait que l'homme
tradition c'est normal pour 38% des
femmes 52% des hommes d'extirper ses
habitudes
il faut le faire parce que c'est le lit
des violences ultérieures et il faut
absolument prendre le mal à la racine
parce que une fois que le pli est pris
que les petits garçons envahissent la
cour d'école que les filles sont
reléguées qu'elles sont victimes de
cyber-harcèlement c'est parti et c'est
foutu pour la vie donc il faut et je
suis on est tous d'accord là-dessus
mettre un paquet énorme sur l'éducation
c'est un scandale que ça fait 20 ans que
la loi plus de 20 ans maintenant que la
loi a été votée c'était la loi Aubry qui
prévoyait qui est au moins trois séances
d'éducation dès le primaire jusqu'à la
terminale éducation sexuelle d'éducation
à l'égalité au consentement ça serait le
minimum il le faut le faire peut-être
encore plus mais déjà au moins appliquer
la loi et nous proposons
adapter à chaque tranche d'âge et c'est
la seule manière de compenser les
ravages d'Internet et du numérique parce
que une des explications
votre avis de cet état de fait des
jeunes adultes c'est qu'ils ont été
biberonnés aux réseaux sociaux au porno
à la violence banalisée au traitement
dégradant des femmes et donc forcément
il reflète les modèles et autant la
télévision a été régulée la télévision
et les grandes plateformes là c'est
toutes les petites questions à Frédéric
leicesterflag vous qui enseignez la
science pour Sciences Po on sait à
l'avant-garde de ces sujets les
étudiants les ont pris abrahaltor les
enseignants aussi sont amenés à suivre
des formations sur ces questions bien
sûr on a des formations violences
sexistes et sexuelles qui nous obligent
aussi en tant qu'enseignant à prendre
notre part du travail par exemple à
prendre conscience de nos biais on note
pas de la même manière statistiquement
des garçons et les filles alors c'est
bien de s'en rendre compte parce qu'on
peut peut-être corriger quelque chose
dans notre attitude on n'attend pas on
n'attend pas la même la même disposition
à parler à l'oral on n'a pas les mêmes
manière de exigeant avec les filles
qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire c'est des
outils un petit peu complexes et
difficiles à résumer mais globalement on
a des formations qui nous rendent
conscients de ces biais pour tenter de
de les corriger dans notre pratique au
quotidien et ce qui me ce qui m'amène à
dire que ce baromètre en fait c'est
formidable qu'il existe on c'est un
outil remarquable et vraiment c'est un
progrès d'avoir un outil comme ça mais
il me semble qu'on aurait besoin de
l'affiner encore davantage parce que
vous rappeliez ce slogan on sait pas
comment ça commence on sait comment ça
finit mais moi j'ai envie de vous dire
on a besoin de savoir aussi comment ça
commence et pour savoir comment ça
commence par où ça arrive en particulier
cette régression générationnelle on a
besoin peut-être d'outils d'analyse un
peu plus fin pour comprendre par où ça
revient en fait ce sexisme sur les
jeunes générations et il y a une
analogie qui me qui me venait en tête on
vous écoutant il y a un autre sujet sur
lequel on a une régression
générationnelle c'est la laïcité où on
se rend compte que les jeunes généra
sont moins favorables à la laïcité que
les générations plus anciennes et bien
sûr c'est deux sujets où on pensait
finalement qu'il y avait une progression
continue il y a une intersection entre
les données
on a un problème de transmission aux
jeunes générations et donc on a besoin
d'outils plus fin de diagnostic pour
savoir par où ça vient d'accord avec ça
oui pierre brossolète
des moyens supplémentaires pour affiner
ce baromètre mais je pense
malheureusement que la réponse est assez
claire l'éducation dans quoi on baigne
on baigne dans son milieu familial
dans le milieu médiatique et numérique
et à l'école et dans ces trois endroits
le sexisme est encore roi c'est comme ça
et pour faire évoluer le sexisme comme
on n'a pas vraiment barre sur le milieu
familial parce que c'est quand même la
vie privée il faut avoir une action très
ferme énergique sur l'éducation et le
numérique c'est les deux choses qui
forment les mentalités et pour faire
évoluer les choses il faut prendre des
mesures obligatoires
on se souvient des difficultés du
judiciaires pour réussir à interdire
certains comptes etc même s'il y a eu
des lois notamment après l'assassinat de
Samuel Paty il y a des lois qui ont été
mises en place vous vous attendez quoi
parce qu'on voit vraiment que la
violence à l'état brute elle finit par
imprégner les jeunes à travers les
grandes plateformes à travers les
réseaux sociaux qu'est-ce que vous
attendez du législateur puisqu'on est à
l'Assemblée nationale écoutez ça
d'ailleurs été préconisé dans le dans le
rapport c'est-à-dire un contrôle des
réseaux un contrôle internet
s'agissons des images dégradantes du
vocabulaire dégradons vis-à-vis des
femmes et de la pornographie des images
pornographiques donc on attend un
contrôle maintenant qui dit contrôle
forcément
dysfonction après ça reste très
problématique de passionné ce qui poste
certaines images sur les réseaux parce
que l'identité n'est pas forcément
Maxime rusianké
l'ambiance mais sur autant le contrôle
et Sylvie connaît bien parce que elle a
été dans cette institution mais autant
le compte à la com pardon de la
télévision et on voit que c'est
difficile parce qu'il y a des émissions
qui ont été condamnées pour des fêtes
sexistes très graves et qui sont
toujours à l'antenne et quotidiennement
donc même à la télévision je suis pas
très optimiste mais sur internet le flux
est incessant donc en fait oui il faut
des sanctions oui il faut du contrôle
évidemment je je suis d'accord avec vous
mais il faut aussi être imaginatif c'est
à dire qu'il faut créer des contenus qui
parlent aux jeunes qui soient davantage
pédagogique qui parle d'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes mais avec leur
code avec leur manière de parler avec
leur manière de s'exprimer parce que si
on ne on n'essaie pas d'avoir des
actions proactives et si on se contente
juste de sanctionner de leur dire c'est
pas bien ce que vous regardez c'est pas
bien ce que vous faites il est évident
que cette génération
absolument mais c'est aussi c'est aussi
portefeuille les diffuseurs sur Internet
vous avez 15% du chiffre d'affaires de
Youtube c'est beaucoup d'argent donc si
c'était sanctionné parce que normalement
la digitte le service acte va donner la
possibilité de régulateur d'exiger des
plateformes qui mettent de se reposer de
se responsabiliser et si on constate que
ce n'est pas fait on peut mettre des
sanctions financières importantes et
quand on touche au portefeuille c'est
comme ça que j'ai persuadé deux groupes
canal énergie de ne plus mettre
de de séquences dégradante pour les
femmes à l'antenne il y a d'autres excès
copper mais le portefeuille c'est
malheureusement ça fonctionne mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que c'est bien de
sanctionner ce qui ont le pouvoir donc
les médias les institutions mais en fait
il faut aussi que du positif oui mais il
faut aussi que individuellement en aille
vers des choses positives un exemple
très concret moi très souvent on me dit
mais vous les féministes vous voulez
faire la loi dans les foyers vous voulez
nous dire quoi penser quoi après tout si
ma femme préfère cuisiner qu'est-ce que
ça peut vous faire et en fait moi ce que
j'explique en permanence c'est que
personne ne veut s'immiscer dans la vie
de monsieur et madame tout le monde en
revanche ce qu'on explique c'est que ça
produit des effets sur les jeunes
générations une petite fille qui voit
sans arrêt comme le disait Sylvie sa
mère qui se déplace pour faire à manger
pour débarrasser forcément elle va
intérioriser ce cliché elle va le
reproduire peut-être plus tard donc
finalement cette responsabilité
au niveau individuel même si et je suis
bien d'accord ce sont celles et ceux qui
détiennent les reines des médias et de
l'éducation aussi puisque ça va passer
par une révolution à l'école qui vont
aussi transformer la société on a parlé
de l'école on parle des réseaux sociaux
les actions Boncelles c'est vrai qu'il
faut rappeler que c'était quand même la
grande cause du quinquennat 2017 ça
l'est à nouveau en 2022 qu'est-ce que
vous en attend internet parce que je
voulais aussi juste nuancer peut-être un
peu les choses parce qu'en réalité ce
qu'on a vu ces dernières années c'est
dix dernières années c'est que ont pu
émerger sur Internet et grâce à internet
des contenus d'éducation féministe
exceptionnelles que le nouveau tel
toujours pas d'ailleurs dans les dire
traditionnel et notamment à la
télévision moi je me suis lancé grâce à
un podcast c'est un format qui n'aurait
pas pu exister à la télévision je fais
intervenir que des femmes pour parler de
politique ce n'est chose c'est les
choses qui n'existent pas j'ai pu le
faire que parce que le podcast me
permettait de le faire donc je pense que
c'est important aussi nuancer de
rencontre un grand succès parfois
supérieur à certaines scènes de télé
les séquences les plus OBD
en quelque sorte est une formidable
liberté il y a eu beaucoup d'acquis mais
comme toutes les libertés il y a aucune
raison qu'elle ne soit pas encadrées et
qu'elle ne répondent pas à des règles ce
n'est en rien à tenter ou reprocher
internet sa liberté de communication
Nathalie tomatini je voudrais juste
répondre à ce qui vient d'être dit je ne
suis pas tout à fait d'accord avec la
responsabilité individuelle que vous
prenez à savoir que un individu IR
reproduit des modèles et des schémas
donc il y a une responsabilité sociétale
et une responsabilité gouvernementale
dont justement tout ce qui fait se
sexisme ambiant qu'on vous dites il faut
que chacun se responsabilise dans le
huis clos familial nous c'est c'est
l'égalité à l'époque parce que la
société a freiné mais parce que c'est
une c'est un idéal que vous prenez mais
l'individu en tant que tel mais bien sûr
que si l'individu reproduit il est exoté
pourrait vous répondre à l'époque le
gouvernement voulait faire un
apprentissage à l'égalité des écoles on
va parler tout à l'heure c'est le
gouvernement qui a voulu le faire qui a
freiné c'est la société civile sont les
individus polémiques
c'est différent de l'individu en tant
que tel et vous parliez je parlais de la
responsabilité du peuple français pour
l'égalité
moi ce que je voudrais qu'on comprenne
c'est que si on en est là aujourd'hui
c'est parce qu'on n'a pas essayé de
travailler d'une manière globale et
sociétale comme je vous le disais on est
impacté par les médias la culture l'art
l'éducation si sur toutes ces domaines
là on avait cette priorité affichée du
gouvernement de lutter contre le sexisme
et les violences
le cinéma aujourd'hui n'est-ce pas
on pourrait continuer longtemps c'est le
VIP Pierre Brossolette malheureusement
doit nous quitter rapidement est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire comment il a été
reçu ce rapport par Emmanuel Macron
est-ce qu'il s'est engagé sur quelques
propositions des recommandations du
rapport ce qui nous a satisfait c'est
qu'il a eu l'air d'avoir très bien
compris que pour mieux lutter contre les
violences faites aux femmes il suffisait
pas de protéger les femmes ce qu'il faut
faire et de sanctionner les auteurs ce
qu'il faut faire mais qu'il fallait
prendre le mal en amont et là un déclic
j'ai l'impression ces produits il a été
d'accord alors après on verra s'il est
les actions suivent mais
intellectuellement en tout cas jusqu'ici
j'ai l'impression que le gouvernement
jusqu'au plus haut niveau de l'État
pas compris l'importance du sexisme en
général et se contentait de lutter
contre les violences et là il y a une
prise de conscience j'ai l'impression
pourvu qu'elle soit suivie d'action sur
le fait qu'il faut prendre le mal à la
racine en tous les cas malgré le 1000
tours malgré tout ce qui a été fait la
réalité ne bouge pas tant que ça et
c'est ce qu'il faut retenir de ce
rapport merci beaucoup merci d'être venu
débattre sur le plateau de LCP vous
restez avec moi Frédéric leisterflack
dans une dizaine de minutes les parties
pris de nos affranchis ce soir le gros
coup de coeur de Bertrand Perrier pour
le retour de Starmania le mot de la
semaine de notre sémiologue Mariette
Darrigrand c'est le mot réforme retraite
oblige et puis Bourbon express avec
Marco Bobby l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée mais d'abord la littérature
face au scandale du mal c'est le parti
pris de votre essai passionnant Frédéric
leicesterflack pourquoi le mal frappe
les gens bien pourquoi le covid
fauchelin et pas l'autre la tornade
telle maison plutôt que telle autre la
guerre tel enfant plutôt que tel autre
pourquoi aussi la Phil et la religion ne
suffisent pas pour répondre à ces
questions on voit cela tout de suite
dans l'invitation signée ce soir par
mail tes Frémont et on en parle ensemble
juste après
[Musique]
si on vous invite Frédéric lichterfly
c'est parce que vous sortez un nouvel
essai qui nous interpelle qui ne sait
pas un jour posé cette question pourquoi
le mal frappe les jambes bien pourquoi
le sort s'acharne-t-il sur l'un et pas
sur l'autre pourquoi moi et pas lui
peut-on accepter que les enfants
souffrent des interrogations éthiques et
morales ou ni la philosophie ni la
religion ne livre de réponse claire à
vos yeux alors vous explorez une autre
voix vous puiser dans la littérature et
dans ces récif fictionnelles pour
affronter le réel la littérature c'est
une réserve de cas particuliers et dans
la vraie vie quand on traverse
une épreuve une expérience quelconque on
ne rencontre que du cas particulier
c'est toujours du singulier on improvise
toujours dans le réel on improvise mais
toujours à partir de source à partir de
modèles qui peuvent nous servir de guide
et vous faites appel au personnage de
Marguerite Yourcenar avec xénon le héros
Phil de Victor Hugo de Shakespeare et
son roi Lyr ou encore de Dostoïevski et
de Kafka Frédéric lichterflack vous êtes
normalienne chercheuse et universitaire
vous enseignez les humanités et à vos
étudiants vous proposez l'étude de
grandes œuvres de fiction pour réfléchir
sur les questions éthiques politiques et
juridiques du moment et dans notre
société le débat moral s'invite sur tous
les terrains terrorisme virus
catastrophe écologique les ressources de
la littérature sont pour vous un
laboratoire des cas de conscience
ancienne membre du comité d'éthique au
CNRS vous avez déjà écrit plusieurs
ouvrages dont qui vivra Kimura quand on
ne peut pas sauver tout le monde une
fiction contemporaine avec cette
question a-t-on le droit de sacrifier
une vie pour en sauver plusieurs on est
quelques-uns à travailler sur ces
questions de de choix d'arbitrage pas de
triage qu'est-ce qu'on fait quand on
peut pas sauver tout le monde à qui vont
les ressources trop rares pour être
distribuées à l'ensemble de la
population et là d'un coup cette
situation non seulement elle devient
notre locotidien mais surtout elle
devient visible à les poser sur la place
publique elle est débattue par tout le
monde et n'importe qui alors Frédéric
Lichter flag puisque la littérature à ce
pouvoir comment s'en servir de façon
concrète pour construire collectivement
des réponses à toutes ces crises qui
nous frappent
réponse Frédéric lichtoflack finalement
ce pouvoir de la littérature pour nous
accompagner face au scandale du mal il
n'est qu'individuel ou on pourrait
imaginer des réponses collectives à une
échelle plus grande en tout cas la
lecture des grandes oeuvres c'est un
support de délibération collectiviste il
s'agit pas de répondre à des questions à
mon titre c'est une question mais ce
serait un descendant envisager même
qu'on puisse répondre par parce que à
cette question pourquoi le mal frappe
les gens bien l'idée c'était de prendre
un une question symptômes et de lui
donner du crédit de la prendre au
sérieux c'est pas une question naïve
c'est pas juste une question d'enfant
même si ça a l'air d'être un
questionnement sur le problème du mal à
hauteur d'enfant mais en réalité d'abord
c'est une question qu'on se pose tous et
à travers l'histoire de l'humanité fil
de nos rencontres avec le mauvais sort
avec la maladie avec le deuil avec la
malchance avec la déception avec la
catastrophe et puis ce sont des
questions qui nous sont revenues en
pleine figure avec ses expériences
collectives qu'on a traversé le covid ou
le souligner il y a un instant mais
aussi les attentats les attentats qui
ont remis dans notre vie la conscience
de notre impuissance à maîtriser le sort
à contenir l'aléa qui peut frapper à
tout moment et donc ce sont des très
très vieilles questions dans l'histoire
de la philosophie pourquoi les innocents
souffrent pourquoi l'aléa pourquoi des
choses affreuses peuvent arriver à des
gens qui ne les méritent pas ce sont de
très vieilles questions philosophiques
qui frappent le monde entier vous vous
aimez dire que vous vous êtes professeur
de littérature mais vous venez de
l'histoire et de la philosophie vous
avez dit c'est des questions
philosophiques par excellence des
questions même métaphysiques et vous
vous dites souvent j'y répond avec la
littérature je fais de la philosophie
avec la littérature qu'est-ce que ça
signifie ça
ça signifie que d'abord on n'est pas des
êtres de concept ou d'argumentation on
est surtout des êtres de récit on vit au
milieu d'histoire quand on a un problème
on se raconte des histoires et c'est ça
qui nous permet de le de le traverser et
puis surtout la littérature elle nous
installe au niveau des émotions et sur
une question comme celle du mal le
scandale du mal il me semble que
l'émotion de scandale ce ce degré zéro
de la réflexion qui consiste à dire mais
les bras mentons je suis sidérée parce
qu'il arrive comment la vie peut être
aussi injuste avec moi ou en général
pour mériter ça exactement mais pas dans
la version comique de la question dans
la version sérieuse mais il y a là une
émotion le scandale est une émotion et
il me semble que cette émotion elle a de
la valeur et ce que fait la littérature
c'est qu'elle cherche pas à l'apaiser
elle cherche pas à refermer le le
français la blessure la béance au
contraire elle part des émotions de
scandale et elle lui donne de la force
de la valeur et je crois paradoxalement
que c'est plus efficace pour prendre en
charge la blessure et la souffrance la
philosophie donne des réponses
intellectuelles oui d'abord que de
chercher à consoler en disant c'est pas
si grave ou bien c'est parce que tu
crois ou bien c'est pas vraiment le mal
ou bien la souffrance c'est un sens tout
ça c'est pas respecté la figé pas
respecter l'enduillé et puis la
littérature elle va questionner elle va
remettre en question les réponses de la
philosophie elle nous montre que dans le
réel on a toujours affaire à des cas
particuliers c'est toujours singulier ça
rentre jamais exactement dans les cases
conceptuelles prévues les réponses de la
philosophie et puis les réponses de la
religion on va prendre quelques œuvres
des grands récits de malheurs dans
lesquels vous puisez pour répondre à
cette question du mal du scandale du mal
le livre de Job on va avoir une
représentation la très rapidement le
voilà job entouré de ses amis
rappelez nous Satan va dire adieu au
fond il est trop bien pour être
véritablement vertueux job c'est ça oui
c'est le probablement le plus vieux
récit dont on dispose qui raconte
l'histoire sans cesse renouvelée du
juste qui souffre job c'est le meilleur
d'entre les hommes il est tellement bien
il est tellement parfait il est
tellement exemplaire que Dieu le
personnage de Dieu dans ce récit
biblique l'a pris en exemple et c'est
vanter à la cour des anges en disant job
vous avez vu mon serviteur celui-là il
est exceptionnel et Satan alors Satan
dans la bbraïque c'est pas le diable
c'est le l'ange accusateur celui qui est
chargé de porter le soupçon Satan lui
dit mais est-ce qu'on en est bien sûr
tout lui sourit la vie lui est facile à
ce qu'on peut vraiment être sûr que son
intégrité son honnêteté sa piété tout ça
c'est désintéressé et une fois qu'il a
dit ça c'est fichu parce que la seule
manière de s'en le doute c'est
exactement le soupçon nous accompagne et
la seule manière de faire le test c'est
de donner carte blanche à Satan et de
laisser job frapper d'une pluie de
malheur qui lui tombe sur la tête plus
abominable les uns que les autres ses
enfants ses 10 enfants il va être malade
exactement et pourquoi moi alors cette
question
job cela pose alors job et puis ses amis
la déplace en fait job cela pose mais
assez brièvement parce que il a d'emblé
décidé que rien de ce qu'il aurait pu
faire
ne pourrait justifier être
proportionnelle à un châtiment pareil
donc lui campe sur l'injustice il ne
cédera jamais au fond à cette
culpabilité qu'on attend de lui c'est
souvent pour les amis pour les
observateurs que le problème se pose
quand on voit quelqu'un de bien frappé
par le malin on se dit mais de deux
choses l'une soit la vie n'a vraiment
aucun sens on peut rien maîtriser on n'a
aucune prise sur rien et et on est au
milieu du scandale et on sait pas quoi
faire de ce non sens soit on va chercher
se dire il y a peut-être mais il y a
peut-être quelque chose de mérité et les
amis job qu'est-ce qui font ben
il rebondit sur cette question tu veux
savoir pourquoi toi moi on va chercher
pourquoi lui on va trouver l'explication
et pour eux le malheur ne peut être
qu'une punition qu'un châtiment alors
que Job ne s'aidera jamais job ne cède
pas il défend notre dignité humaine dans
cette histoire l'injustice est
insupportable mais ce qui est le plus
insupportable et ce qui rend fou c'est
du sort et face à cela il y a ceux qui
s'indignent et on pense au refus d'Yvan
Karamazov oui alors ça c'est un passage
magnifique effectivement que je commande
dans des frères Amazon c'est un chapitre
qui peut d'ailleurs être lune manière
complètement autonome il s'appelle une
révolte ou une rébellion dans selon les
traductions et ils vont vers Amazon
s'adresse à son jeune frère qui est
novice dans le monastère local il veut
lui parler du problème du mal des
souffrances des innocentes pourquoi des
choses affreuses se passent à la surface
de la Terre pourquoi Dieu laisse faire
et comment on peut s'accommoder d'un
monde où ceci arrive mais il va prendre
un exemple particulièrement probant un
exemple tellement puissant que son jeune
frère Aliocha pourra pas lui dire oui
mais il y a le monde d'après il y a la
rédemption il y a ce qui se passe après
la mort il y a la justice de Dieu dans
la vie d'après les réponses de la
religion vont être inopérantes parce que
l'exemple que prend Yvan Karamazov c'est
celui de la souffrance des enfants et il
raconte une demi dou de petites
vignettes d'enfants martyrisés et là on
se rend compte en écoutant que le
problème du mal c'est pas le problème de
la malveillance de la malfaisance de la
méchanceté tout ça finalement pour le
dire dans le dans les mots de
divan karamazon on sait bien pourquoi
l'homme est méchant ils vont rien
l'homme on le sait pourquoi il fait le
mal c'est pas ça le problème le problème
c'est la souffrance c'est la déréliction
c'est l'abandon c'est le c'est l'émotion
bouleversée de l'enfant qui souffre et
qui comprend pas pourquoi ça lui arrive
voilà et c'est de la compare la question
de la souffrance des enfants et je fais
un pont forcément avec Philippe Roth
Nemesis et Cantor ce héros de Philippe
Roth qui lui ne va pas supporter un peu
comme Karamazov on ne va pas supporter
cette épidémie alors laquelle voilà quel
don du biscuitité de quelle prédiction
cette épidémie qui va frapper après
guerre ou pendant la guerre les
États-Unis et qui va choisir
quelques enfants et qui ne va pas
frapper tous les enfants mais
statistiquement certainement une
minorité d'entre eux et ça le héros de
Philippe ne le supportera oui c'est ce
qui est extraordinaire avec Nemesis
c'est le dernier roman de Philippe rod
donc 2010
il veut réfléchir sur l'alléa du mal et
je pense que ce qu'il a aussi en tête
c'est une autre forme du mal de violence
politique qui est probablement
l'expérience de la Shoah est-ce que ça a
modifié de notre acceptabilité des
réponses religieuses comment comment
encore croire comment encore n'ont pas
croire mais faire confiance à un Dieu
qui a pu laisser faire ça et Philippe
Roth il va chercher l'exemple de
l'épidémie et d'une épidémie toute
particulière une épidémie polio qui
frappe des enfants tout particulièrement
et il nous offre un personnage alors qui
est pas du tout un modèle on doit pas
suivre ces traces mais que la question
du mal et de la souffrance des enfants
et de l'alléa de cette mort grande
faucheuse qui va chercher ses victimes
au hasard
sans considération des mérites des uns
et des autres bien entendu il va
chercher cette question et il nous l'a
il la formule effectivement comme un
comme un scandale avec lequel son
personnage s'étouffe en réalité son
héros n'arrive plus à vivre iron non sa
vie alors c'est pas un modèle pour nous
mais ensuite le cheminement psychique
existentielle morale le reçu du
personnage de Philippe Roth d'accepter
de vivre dans un monde où de telles
choses se passent combien
ça nous ça nous oblige à reformuler nos
questions à nous débarrasser des
mauvaises réponses et puis à sauver
quelque chose de cette flamme de ce
scandale qui est
l'indignation insatiable de la terminer
et pour faire le lien avec vos autres
travaux la question des quatre
consciences la question des choix
éthiques et si on a eu l'importance ce
sont ceux qui ont dû être faits pendant
pendant le covid vous diriez que dans
certains cas de figure il il y a des
morts qui sont préférables à d'autres
quand on ne peut pas sauver tout le
monde alors c'est difficile de le dire
comme ça parce que c'est une formule qui
va pas priorité tabou mais il y a des
morts plus scandaleuses que d'autres
c'est difficile d'avoir cette discussion
collective les uns avec les autres mais
on l'a vu très bien au moment de la
pandémie au départ ça a commencé cette
histoire de pandémie par nous renvoyer
en pleine figure l'expérience de de
l'aller à la grande faucheuse on
maîtrisait rien c'était l'aléa du sort
et puis très vite on s'est rendu compte
que sous l'aléa il y avait des couches
sociologiques qui avaient des
déterminants qu'on était plus ou moins
exposés selon son métier qu'en réalité
on avait prises d'une certaine manière
l'accès aux soins par exemple qui on va
soigner d'abord à qui on va donner la
priorité qui on va protéger en priorité
les vaccins aurai accès aux respirateurs
les fameux respirateurs quand on pouvait
pas sauver la prise en réalité sur la
répartition que ce soit les critères
décidaient démocratiquement vous pensez
que ça y est les sociétés sont prêtes
alors avoir ces débats si on est on est
prêt à avoir ce débat mais en tout cas
on a commencé à le poser sur la table
avec la question du tri du triage au
moment de la pandémie quand les choses
se sont un peu apaisées on a remis le
sujet sous le tapis mais il me semble
qu'on a besoin d'avoir cette discussion
cette mise en abyme de la société tout
entière au fond on ne fait que ça en
permanence les politiques publiques les
politiques de rationnement des soins
médicaux ne sont que des manières de
déplacer la main de l'ange de la mort on
fait ça tout le temps mais sans le dire
peut-être qu'il serait temps de le dire
merci beaucoup pour rester avec moi
Frédéric lichterfly parce qu'on va
accueillir nos affranchis dans un
instant pourquoi le mal frappe les gens
bien c'est à dire chez Flammarion et ça
donne envie de relire ou de relire et
même de les découvrir les grands de la
littérature de notre patrimoine mondial
littéraire allez les affranchis on les
accueille tout de suite vous allez voir
leur partie prix vont vous faire réagir
et bonsoir à vous bienvenue bonsoir
Bertrand Bertrand Perrier maître Perrier
vous avez un coup de cœur ce soir je
crois pour une comédie musicale qui
revient après 40 ans d'absence Starmania
bonsoir Mariette Mariette darrigance
c'est mieux là qui a choisi un mot cette
semaine le mot raiforme forcément les
retraites oblige on commence avec
Bourbon Express comme chaque soir c'est
l'histoire du jour à l'assemblée qui
nous est racontée ce soir par Marco Polo
bonsoir Marco une histoire d'accès
d'accessibilité ce soir oui je vous
raconte l'histoire d'un petit chantier
objectif rendre l'hémicycle 100%
accessible à Sébastien Petavy député
écologiste de Dordogne il aura fallu six
mois pour réaliser les aménagements les
pensées les réaliser mardi dernier
c'était jour de rentrée pour le député
et il a posé sa toute première question
au gouvernement à séquence forcément
symbolique
ainsi ma question est simple comment
comptez-vous réellement prendre en
compte la pénibilité pour les métiers du
soin et de l'accompagnement qu'il soit
en ville ou à l'hôpital à domicile ou en
EHPAD ou auprès des personnes en
situation de handicap monsieur le député
pétavie permettez-moi d'abord si
l'autoriser à vous dire au nom du
gouvernement que nous sommes heureux que
votre état de santé vous permet de nous
rejoindre et de participer à nos travaux
et là le député périgourdin qui se
réjouit de descendre sur le ring au
moment de la bataille contre la réforme
des retraites alors Myriam vous allez me
dire un député paraplégique qui exerce
son mandat rien de plus normal en
théorie c'est vrai sauf que sauf que le
Palais Bourbon il était pas vraiment
adapté aux personnes en situation de
handicap un oubli embarrassant mise en
lumière par l'élection de Sébastien
Petavy en juin dernier l'occasion pour
l'Assemblée nationale et bien de
procéder à quelques travaux quelques
aménagements pour l'accueillir
alors Sébastien Payet la vie ici on est
dans votre bureau qu'est-ce qui a changé
la moquette la moquette pourquoi vous
pouvez voir voilà dans le couloir en
fait c'est une moquette qui est beaucoup
plus moelleuse donc en fait le fauteuil
s'enfonce davantage et donc voilà
changement de moquette pour pouvoir
mieux rouler dans mon bureau bon et ben
écoutez on vous suit maintenant jusqu'à
l'hémicycle c'est parti c'est parti
on a donc fait le parcours avec
Sébastien Petavy depuis son bureau il
faut savoir que l'assemblée a aménagé sa
chambre de députée un accès à des
toilettes et à la commission des
affaires sociales où il siège le plus
gros des travaux c'était donc dans
l'hémicycle pour y accéder bien le
député utilise un nom de charge vous
allez le voir sur ces images voilà le
voilà ce monte-charge et dans cette
émission et bien impossible pour lui de
monter dans les rangs donc on lui a
trouvé une place de choix au premier
rang juste à côté des ministres écoutez
donc désormais c'est votre place de
députés juste ici et on a installé une
rampe c'est ça oui
à cet endroit là donc ils ont enlevé le
siège et ils ont pu fabriquer sa trame
cette rampe et pouvoir donc installer un
pupitre ah oui le pupitre rouge
carrément ça permet en fait pour le
fauteuil de d'arrivée de pouvoir pivoter
s'installer bon et alors pendant les
questions gouvernement vous êtes juste à
côté des ministres c'est pas dérangeant
d'être à côté de alors qu'ils sont pas
dans votre corps on peut en profiter
pour poser certaines questions
voilà Sébastien Petavy un député pas
tout à fait comme les autres mais il
prévient il ne veut pas s'exprimer
uniquement sur le sujet on l'a vu
d'ailleurs sur la question ça posera pas
son seul combat même s'il le sait aussi
hein sa présence dans l'hémicycle elle
porte un message merci c'est vrai que
dans les personnes en situation de
handicap il y a beaucoup de personnes
qui sont valorisées à travers le sport
mais c'est vrai que dans la question
politique par exemple c'est pas le cas
je crois que ça peut donner des idées
des envies à certaines personnes de
pouvoir le faire et ça c'est très bien
voilà Sébastien Petavy et le premier
député handicapé en fauteuil roulant à
l'Assemblée nationale sous la 5ème
république voilà et qui a enfin la
possibilité de pouvoir largement siéger
exercer son mandat merci beaucoup Marco
on enchaîne avec vous le mot de la
semaine réforme réforme des retraites
obligent j'ai pas regardé sur Google les
occurrences mais je pense que le pic
d'audience est élevé pour ce mot un pic
très élevé mais malheureusement assez
négatif c'est quand même assez curieux
pour moi il y a un mystère sémiologique
c'est un des mots les plus négatifs de
la langue politique et pourtant il est
utilisé de plus en plus par les
politiques et les observateurs bon alors
c'est quand même un peu curieux et
j'avais eu un peu un moment d'espoir au
moment de la présidentielle de 2017
parce que Emmanuel Macron précisément
n'a pas utilisé le mot et je pense que
c'est une des raisons d'ailleurs pour
lesquelles il a été élu parce qu'au fond
il disait la France va se moderniser
sans se réformer il parlait de
transformation il aimait bien ce terme
réformé ça veut pas dire moderniser
alors aujourd'hui non je crois que ça ne
plus dire moderniser j'ai l'impression
qu'on garde une sorte de trace vous
savez quand il y avait le service
militaire et puis qu'on disait à
certains qu'ils étaient réformés donc
ils n'étaient pas bons pour le service
il me semble que c'est ça n'existe plus
service militaire mais on en a gardé
cette chose là qui est quand même
curieuse parce que au départ et là il
faut prendre le mot réforme avec son r
majuscule la réforme voilà événement
majeur culturel et politique majeures de
notre histoire européenne et à ce
moment-là au contraire la réforme elle
représente en effet une forme de
basculisterie on dirait aujourd'hui de
modernisation contre les institutions
l'église voir la Sorbonne et bien là la
liberté de conscience commence à émerger
et justement Emmanuel Macron lui se dit
réformateur absolument et je pense que
c'est tout à fait en connaissance de
cause en référence à cette histoire
protestante de la France on pourrait
dire il était proche de Paul Ricard mais
il le fait comment dire avec une volonté
politique comme s'il voulait dire qu'il
lui-même il allait marquer une rupture
fondamentale dans l'histoire de notre
pays en avant et un après Macron si on
veut parce que le terme normal politique
ce serait réformiste
a disparu un peu avec le Parti
socialiste on pourrait dire avec la
crise de la social démocratie alors
dernièrement en date quand même ça m'a
beaucoup marqué François Ruffin qui
n'était pas du côté de la réforme mais
de la révolution pour dire a repris le
mot réformiste dernièrement et dans la
même dit qu'il était social-démocrate
voilà et dans les couloirs de
l'Assemblée hier je crois je l'ai enfin
je l'ai entendu à travers votre votre
chronique sur l'assemblée dire que il
considérait la réforme des retraites
quoi comme la Contre Réforme absolument
donc là c'est vrai on est quasiment dans
la guerre de religion voilà alors
heureusement on en est plus là en France
mais je crois qu'il y a quand même une
guerre des connotations c'est à dire que
la réforme des retraites fait penser au
système libéral des pays anglo-saxons
souvent protestants versus la défense au
nom de l'État providence de l'état divin
qui donne qui protège ses enfants donc
vous nous sommes héritiers des sens
comme ça
positifs ou négatifs selon le l'endroit
où on se place du mot réforme donc pour
boucler si vous voulez ce que je dirais
Myriam que par rapport à votre question
du début c'est que non la réforme n'est
plus elle s'est retournée elle n'est
plus comme au départ synonyme de
modernité si on veut et puis elle a
perdu ce sens très beau qu'elle avait à
l'origine parce que la forme en latin la
forme c'était aussi la beauté donc les
réformateurs demandaient à revenir à la
beauté des textes bibliques les
écritures comme comme on disait alors
qu'aujourd'hui si on revient à mon avis
c'est plutôt un peu en arrière retour à
un âge d'or il ne serait pas un âge
pivot mais un âge d'or et là peut-être
62 ans voire 60 ans merci
en tout cas c'est jamais innocent les
mots qu'on emploie et notamment dans ce
moment de tension autour des retraites
Bertrand votre coup de cœur vous avez eu
la chance parce que c'est complet vous
allez voir star le retour 40 ans après
oui c'est un peu l'un des spectacles
dont on parle ça fait presque trois mois
que un public très intergénérationnel se
presse chaque soir à la scène musicale à
Boulogne-Billancourt pour voir la
recréation du spectacle de 1979 c'est
pas exactement la même chose mais c'est
une réinvention c'est absolument
magnifique la mise en scène de Thomas
Joly insiste sur le côté très sombre de
l'univers de la ville de Monopoly sous
se déroule l'intrigue avec un décor
entre gratte-ciel très très lugubre très
oppressant et puis des souterrains
également très effrayants les lumières
sont vraiment magnifiques dans le blues
du businessman dans la pression qu'il
est engagé par des lumières et puis y
aller voir et notamment une voix qui
pour moi a vraiment percé l'écran dans
dans cette soirée c'est la voix du jeune
Alex montambeau qui incarne Marie-Jeanne
le personnage que jouait Fabienne
Thiébaut dans la comédie musicale
initiale qui est absolument bouleversant
et juste un petit extrait
tout ce qu'on veut c'est être heureux
être heureux avant d'être vieux on n'a
pas le temps d'avoir son temps
tout ce qu'on veut
[Musique]
c'est
on a compris que vous avez adoré ça dit
quoi ce succès sur notre société en fait
c'est ça qui est intéressant
indépendamment du côté phénomène c'est
pourquoi est-ce que 40 ans après ça
marche encore et parce que il y a bien
sûr le côté nostalgique le côté
machinature le côté karaoké l'extrait le
monde il y a que des grands tubes besoin
d'amour quand on arrive en ville Ziggy
les uns contre les autres c'est une
machine à tube et c'est un grand karaoké
dans la scène musical mais au-delà il y
a dans ce spectacle de 1979 un côté
totalement prémonitoire et prophétique
regardez l'action se déroule dans une
ville déshumanisée où les individus se
croisent et ne se rencontrent pas le
travail est considéré comme aliénant la
serveuse automate et la jeunesse est à
la dérive au silence entre une forme de
nihilisme et une forme de désespoir et
finalement on se rend compte qu'on est
toujours tout seul au monde c'est bien
notre monde d'aujourd'hui la société est
frappée par la violence d'une bande les
étoiles noires qui arrivent en ville
pour en découdre et tout casser en
particulier les voitures des riches là
encore les luttes de classe sont à
l'oeuvre dans Starmania et puis la
politique le populisme machiavélique
l'ambition démesurée de 0 janvier ce
businessman milliardaire sans scrupule
qui joue sur les peurs de la population
pour accéder au pouvoir en développant
un programme raciste et sécuritaire et
en dénigrants le retour à la nature de
son concurrent le guru marabout
inévitablement ça rappelle des choses et
encore la manipulation des médias par la
politique et puis le couple entre 0
janvier et la starlette Stella Spotlight
le mariage entre un président et une
starlette de cinéma inévitablement ça
fait penser à quelque chose merci
beaucoup des thèmes éternels et puis
voilà les échos de Starmania vous les
avez chantés Frédéric vous les
connaissez tout ça j'étais en train de
les chanter à nouveau pendant la
diffusion de l'extrait bon j'espère
qu'on pourra avoir des places je crois
que c'est à l'automne prochain parce que
c'est complet petit bien ce Bertrand
Périer merci à vous les affranchis merci
Marco et Merci à VOUS Frédéric
leisterflag pourquoi le mal frappe les
gens bien c'est-à-dire chez Flammarion
et puis le laboratoire des quatre
conscience qui vient de sortir également
en poche aux éditions chants et c'est le
weekend profitez bien et à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]